how would you like to follow this the
good news for Satya Nadella is no one
expects him to be Steve Ballmer or for
that matter wants him to be in fact
Nadella is now having to deal with the
tug of war over strategy that hobbled
Microsoft in Ballmer's last years as CEO
co-founder Bill Gates initially
disagreed with Palmers plan to make
mobile devices it didn't help that
Microsoft Surface tablet wasn't done in
Nadella Microsoft promoted a manager
who's proven himself on both the
business and tech sides of the company
of a lifelong winner
he's an electrical engineer from India
who got his MBA at the University of
Chicago Nadella spent 22 years at
Microsoft
he ran the company's R&D unit before
Ballmer named him to head up the server
group the delery engineered that
business into the unit known today as
cloud and enterprise under his
leadership it's risen to number two
worldwide and cloud computing behind
Amazon Nadella is seen as someone who
can help Microsoft innovate faster as it
tries to navigate the post PC world
meantime he can still count on
Microsoft's two biggest moneymakers
windows and office